Okay, I don't know how many times I've got to say it.
You're fuckin crazy. You are genuinely crazy.
I fuckin told you before we hooked up,
I fuckin said this is just a one off thing
and just because I message you and I tell you I love you and shit,
I tell everyone I fuckin love them.
Do you know what I mean? So you're fuckin reading into shit
and your ugly mate Kelsey is pipin up.
Tell her to stop fuckin messaging me because it's annoying as fuck.
A, it's none of her business and b,
she's rank as shit. So you both deserve no one.
I'm gonna go and find a girl who deserves a guy like me
because I'm amazing
and I don't deserve the shit that you stupid bitches are giving me.
So fuck yourself.